how do you define story
a story transports me to a different
place to a different world
to um a world and a life and meeting new
characters
that immersed me
in an entirely new experience you know i
think about some of the
early storytellers in my life like my
grandmother
who was a oral storyteller and she would
tell us stories uh
when we were kids about her life and
you know how she met her husband
stories of our youth when we were
children
so
i like to think of story as
you know there are stories that are
nostalgic with a beginning middle and an
end
but
when i think about stories in general
they're really
a really great
format medium
no matter what kind of medium it is a
place to be transported into a world and
characters that
you might not know it's a it's a way for
you to
um
walk in someone else's shoes
to have empathy
for another character
and to see
someone else's life through their eyes
i think that that's extremely important
for us as
human beings and living in the society
that we live in today
to be able to hear
other people's stories through their own
voices through their unique perspectives
to really
appreciate understand empathize with
how they see the world
um so
i don't know that's a roundabout
answer but uh
story transports you
what is immersive storytelling
immersive storytelling there's many
various definitions for this but in my
mind
it's using tools and techniques
to immerse a guest a participant an
audience member
into an immersive world where they use
all of their senses
in order to immerse themselves in a
particular world or story
and
you know when i think about immersive
storytelling some of the most successful
ones out there
they are the ones that really
think about not just the visual
or the um
you know audio storytelling but in what
you touch and taste and feel
and
and really
have that interaction between different
perhaps different people
or different
elements or objects
that maybe you can pick up that you can
you know explore and discover
and to really feel like you're immersed
in a world or an environment that you
may not necessarily be familiar with but
you have that suspension of disbelief to
allow the storyteller the creator to
take you there to really immerse you in
that
place to play to have permission to
engage
and immerse yourself in something that
you wouldn't normally in your
regular
lives
so to be immersed in that story and
feeling like
you're a part of it feeling like that
you're an important part of it is
extremely important i think too
um that you're not just a spectator that
you are an engaged active participant
in that story
so there are different kinds of
immersive storytelling ones where you do
come into a space and it's extremely
visual and there's music and all of that
but you walk around like
you're perhaps a ghost or you don't
have any effect
to the environment but then there's the
more extreme types of immersive
storytelling
where you are an active participant you
can be a hero to that story and you can
really take part in shaping the outcome
of that story too so there's different
levels of participation levels of
engagement of what you can do in an
immersive storytelling world
does every place have a story
i think so i believe that every place
has a story
this room that we're in has a story uh
this house this town this city
it's a question of who's telling the
story right
um i think that
if you asked the person who lived in
this house
50 years ago versus 100 years ago
versus a thousand years ago right
everyone has a different story to tell
but yes 100
every place has a story and every person
has a story too and
i i find that one of the most
fascinating things to think about
is
you know if you have that chance to tell
the story of yourself or the place that
you're in
what's the story that you want to share
with the world margaret what's your
reaction to someone saying entering a
story is not just an escape i think that
it's
story is um
it is definitely a way for us to
understand and make sense of the world
around us
it's a way for us as children when we
first heard stories and to understand
how
what's right and wrong
the you know the good guys the bad guys
the heroes the villains all of these
things you know what's acceptable what's
not um what's the what's the right
choice to make what's not i think that
for anyone who hears or tells a story
they come
they tell that story through their
personal and unique perspective
and what you pass down from generation
to generation
is what you hope
will live on
in terms of how you make sense of the
world and also how you're not alone
when you hear a story you realize that
there's someone else whether you're
reading a book watching a movie
experiencing a world you realize
there's someone else
in the world who understands exactly how
i feel
and how i live my life and
you know how i
what i dream of and what i hope to do
and what i hope to be one day because a
lot of the stories that
we hear or experience
the ones that really really get into our
hearts and our souls are perhaps
a way to fulfill
a deep-seated desire and a wish that's
something we always think about when we
you know
create any type of stories what is what
is the audience's wish fulfillment
what's their fantasy
and
let's
really get into the heart
of what people not only
want and desire but what they need and
what they're lacking in their lives
so
telling a story
does
create that
understanding and that you know making
sense of the world and you know finding
the
the commonalities between us
and that's something that is really
exciting to me like some of the best
stories
um i've heard or read or experienced
may not have anything to do with
a you know a person that i'm you know or
a culture or a race or a lifestyle or
occupation that i'm familiar with
but because there's so many
common universal truths to
their story
it touches us you know it makes us
understand it makes us
um really connect with someone that
could be from
you know living in the other side of the
world
but you know as
a woman as a mother as a sister as a
daughter
as a human being
being able to
feel that and understand that and make
sense of that
that's really magical to have that
story
really be felt
with every person that experiences that
story that's really
that's really the the goal of every
storyteller isn't it to be able to touch
everyone's lives
in a way that's very meaningful
how is immersive storytelling different
from novel writing or screenwriting yeah
immersive storytelling
is extremely different uh
from
more traditional forms of storytelling
like novels and
screenwriting i think because
the role of the writer the storyteller
is really part of a greater team this is
some this is not a solitary craft um and
you know i love to read books and i love
to watch movies and it's similar with
film production too i i'm i would hope
that you know the writer works with the
director and with the actors and all of
this but i think the role of the writer
and the storyteller in immersive
storytelling
is
extremely um important in that they are
the story champion
and the guardian of that story craft
throughout the you know from the
beginning of the project to the end
because you have to find ways
to be able to embrace and celebrate that
story in various disciplines
you know you talk to the landscape
designer to the architect to the um
audio engineer to the
to the graphic designer in terms of
being able to tell one story one story
world let's say
and it's not
experienced
in just one medium there might be some
media components in an immersive story
world there might be some um you know
graphic uh elements that you're reading
and listening to but as a whole it's a
very holistic type of storytelling
because you are immersing all of your
audience members senses so that every
single detail
of the first moment
a guest an audience member walks into
your experience until the moment they
walk out every single detail
every single thing they touch and feel
and hear and taste is all a part of that
greater story so how do you tell
a story or share a story or have your
audience member partake in that story in
such a way where they feel like
they're the hero and the active and an
active important part of that story and
that's very different from
you know um
reading a novel or watching a movie
where the reader or the audience member
does not take part they're they're
viewers or observers or readers
they don't have a place
in the story
whereas in immersive storytelling
the
audience member the guest
is a part of that story
and they are immersed in this world
where perhaps they can
take action
and you know do and see it and
take action to have consequences in
terms of how the story plays out
so they become
one of the characters to the story and
that's really a big difference
to any other
formats of
storytelling how do people respond when
you explain that your job is to create
an immersive story that you're an
immersive storyteller
they usually question it they're
a lot of them ask what is an immersive
storyteller
why do you need a writer uh to write
immersive stories
uh what do you do exactly i think a lot
of people wonder and question but
they're usually very fascinated with
what that means and i think that
you know it's
it's definitely a growing ever evolving
industry and craft so there's never
there will never be and i hope they
there never will be
a definition to describe what this
immersive storyteller and writer does
in this in any project because it should
evolve
um i don't think
there should be one format or medium to
be able to tell an immersive a really
great immersive story uh i think that
the creators who really push
in terms of like how you would
share an immersive story with the world
um
thinking about how they can just break
the barriers and
really think about how you can tell a
story without characters that you meet
you know live actors how can you tell a
story in an environment where there
isn't anyone in the room
um that's what we do a lot when we
design attractions for theme parks is
when you think about the queue
you don't meet anyone but yet you get
a strong sense of place you get a strong
sense of the character who may inhabit
this place or previously inhabited the
place or the person you're about to meet
right
you get a you get this very strong sense
of place making is what we call it in
the industry
so
there's
people often question that and you know
i start off by saying well
my experience and my what i studied in
film school was to be a writer and
screenwriter
and i kind of
build it up from there so you know i
write for
theme park attractions and rides and
shows and museum experiences and
really trying to make this very uh
holistic type of um storytelling world
where you can experience a story and a
place
in very unique and one-of-a-kind ways
ways
and at the end of the
at for every project you know our goal
is always to
surprise and delight guests and audience
members and visitors so that they can
see the world differently to think about
um you know new ways and new approaches
to living their own lives based on what
they've just experienced
to really hold a mirror to yourself
and to reflect
on what you've experienced
and to reflect on how
you can change your life for the better
how you can really bring you know
positivity
and unity
to your own life and to the world